London's landmarks are classic tourist  magnets but what happens when something  else makes its way into the picture Big  Ben turns into a wristwatch the London  Eye turns into a bicycle and detective  Sherlock hone suddenly finds himself in  focus British photographer rich McCoy  changes the perspectives of famous  landmarks and post the results on  Instagram many of his pictures come from  his travels across Europe from an  aeroplane to a ship the cutouts add a  creative twist to the iconic sights in  Copenhagen he captured the little  mermaid taking a selfie in Paris he  played around with figurines and in  Amsterdam he was reminded of a famous  toon by the police even colorful autumn  leaves Sparky's imagination